we're giving this line here we'll call
it line L okay we want to draw a line
through this point let's call this point
P and we want the line that goes through
this point P to be parallel to line L
okay so how do we do that okay so what
we're going to do is I'm going to start
by drawing a line okay between this
point and point P creating an angle okay
so now you can see we have an angle
right here so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to copy this angle over on
over over here okay using P as the
vertex okay and if these lines if these
angles are congruent these are
corresponding angles and if the
corresponding angles are congruent then
the lines are going to be parallel so
that's what we're going to do so let's
go ahead and start by copying this angle
and if you want you can review one of my
previous videos where I showed you how
to copy an angle but you start off by
drawing an arc okay using this vertex
here then we're gonna come over to this
vertex we're gonna draw another arc okay
and then what we're gonna do is we're
gonna use the compass as a measuring
tool so I'm gonna measure this distance
from here to here okay by adjusting the
compass so if we adjust this like so I'm
just gonna draw a little arc just to
show that I measured that distance I'm
going to come over to here and I'm gonna
also make that same okay arc and then
what we're gonna do is we're going to
draw a line through this point and this
intersection and then we've got it so
let's take a look at that
okay and so there you can see this we
can call this line M for example and you
can see that M is pair a little parallel
to line L and that the reason is is
because if these two angles are
congruent by the converse of the
corresponding angles theorem the two
lines are parallel
so essentially what it is is you're
drawing this Ray and then what you're
doing is you're creating an angle and
you're copying that angle over here
using point P as a vertex and that's how
you do it
so go ahead review the video if you need
to I'll talk to you in the next video